con más de 137 mil casos y más de 200
fallecidos Perú vive la peor epidemia
del dengue en regiones como piura al
norte del país los hospitales están
colapsados y faltan médicos el sistema
sanitario enviará desde Lima
profesionales de salud y medicinas para
atender la emergencia con un hospital
itinerante Perú es un país epidémico de
dengue sobre todo en la selva y la costa
Norte el Ministerio de salud de sanación
cuenta con información para prevenir la
enfermedad y tratarla diversos sectores
critican que el Ministerio de salud y
los gobiernos regionales no actuaron
debidamente para prevenir en lo que va
del año han fallecido más peruanos por
dengue que durante el 2017 por eso el
reproche que hace días atrás la ministra
de salud Rosa Gutiérrez dijo que en 15
días iba a derrotar la epidemia la
posición de muchos peruanos Es que la
ministra renuncie en esa línea
congresistas de diferentes agrupaciones
políticas han presentado una moción de
interpelación contra Rosa Gutiérrez
quien ha sido respaldada en el cargo por
la presidenta Dina boluarte al respecto
la ministra Gutiérrez afirma que no va a
renunciar pero algunos legisladores como
la fujimorista rosángela bárbarán
consideran que si la ministra de salud
No ejecuta una acción efectiva para
combatir la epidemia del dengue debería
dejar el cargo